[Music]
all right hello everyone once again
welcome to another stream the grand
Masters Choice
and today we'll actually be going
through a very special game of mine
that I played in 2017
in the
second round of European individual
where I actually got my second Grand
Master Norm in that tournament and this
game was sort of like the the turning
point for me to really understand what
it means to be a grand master and how
Grandmasters think
um how they play
and potentially even prepare so
we're going to be going through just one
game today
and that's going to be
quite a long one I would say
and it's going to have a lot of ups and
downs so let's get started I'm playing
with the black pieces against Grand
Master Alexander
Mista from Poland and
and the game started off with a
very standard opening the the Ray Lopez
and at that time I basically played a
little bit of everything Maybe
the main lines more than off more than
others but in that game I actually was
preparing against my opponent and kind
of so something I could play that I
thought was worth interesting to play
we got plenty of tactics and everything
you're going to see because I was an
international Master when I played this
game and after this game I basically
understood a little bit more about
um
a little bit more about Grand Masters so
and here I played this move F5 and in a
classical game usually you don't see
this too often especially I mean you do
see it compared to other other lines of
Tory Lopez you don't see it as much
so I played F5 and the reason I played
that is because my opponent pretty much
played more or less the same line
against it although my sample size was
quite small but anyways I prepared this
line F5
and I played this line with Knight F6
which is a little bit more on the solid
side rather than the risky D5 line that
is quite dangerous probably objectively
not so good so my opponent took and he
played Queenie too and as far as I
remember this was exactly what he was
playing in database as well and of
course I was prepared so I played Bishop
E7 takes takes and Knight takes E5 so
black voluntarily gives up the spawn
in the center in order to get the pair
of Bishops and some sort of an activity
I played Queen E6 which is one of the
the main moves obviously of White
Castles black simply plays them of D6
and they will be winning a piece because
of the PIN so Knight F3 was played and
after takes takes I played the move C5
so all of this is basically Theory it
has been played before nothing new so
far but the idea is that black wants to
go Bishop B7 and then attack the Knight
on F3 put pressure on this diagonal
maybe Castle bring the other Rook if
they can there's quite some initiative
happening
so here my opponent played rookie one it
should be seven King F1 and important
move Bishop takes F3 getting rid of this
Knight G takes F3 and I played
look at it so it was all still theory
for me but it wasn't as much theory for
my opponent so here he played the move
Rook E3 but I want to kind of emphasize
that this is all still preparation but
most importantly there is actually a
move called or like D4 but the idea to
sacrifice a pawn but after black takes
white can simply play this move Bishop
G5 attacking this
um
Bishop on E7 where black has to respond
with Rook F7 and like white can respond
with something like Rook E4 with the
idea to attack the pawn on D4
but actually they are threatening Rook
too
um E1 and after black responds with D5
white goes Rook E5 Black Goes Rook d8
white goes rookie one Rook D7 and even
after some
line like this and some Mass trades
we get a pawn and game
that is
pretty drawish after this this and I
don't want to go too much in detail but
you can take my word for it after this
this is all preparation and this would
just somehow lead to a draw at the end
of the day so this is kind of why the
title has how to prep uh think and play
like a grand master the first part the
first phase is I had basically analyzed
every single line within this line if my
opponent played D4 and I had all my
um
variations ready to be able to make a
simple draw after just knowing a lot of
theory so of course when I say simple
it's not always going to be very easy to
make a draw but this is a very important
thing when you're preparing to cover
your bases well otherwise you will be in
a tough spot when you're playing against
the 2600 Grand Master
so my opponent did not play that he
played the move Rook E3 just defending
the pawn I played simply D6 B3 and then
King went to D7 it's kind of getting out
of the pin on the e-file and after
Bishop B2 I played Bishop G5
uh attacking The Rook on E3 and here my
opponent played Rook D3 and in this
moment I actually would like to ask the
the chat uh what would you play if you
were playing with the black pieces here
as I believe my next move was an
inaccuracy from my side and it was quite
a tough moment for me to understand
um I mean I understood it maybe a little
later but
it wasn't so easy to kind of figure out
why this was a mistake during the game
although now it actually makes a lot
more sense
um because I don't think I would ever
make such a move if I were to play with
black again but
in this position there are multiple good
moves Rook F7 is an option for sure
there is the option of playing G6
and there is also the option of playing
this move Bishop to F6 which is with the
idea to trade the Bishops and then get
some activity on the alpha so I see
quite a lot of Rook F7 being suggested
and I also see them of Bishop F6 being
suggested so I would say that um
Rook F7 or G6 would have been the right
choice and unfortunately I played the
smooth Bishop F6 the reason I say it's
unfortunate because simply after Rook F7
or G6
this bishop will be useless forever
whereas my Bishop can actually be more
on the useful side so I could have
easily played the move like Rook F7 and
then doubled up and then played G6 and
then did something else with this bishop
on G5 and this would actually make a lot
more sense but I played Bishop F6 and
the reason this is a mistake is not
because
trading the Bishops and so on it's a
little bit more deeper than that it's
more about what happened maybe in the
next four or five moves maybe like more
like five seven moves you know five to
seven moves so he took I took and here I
was like okay this game is basically
headed to a draw because I'm gonna go
rook f8 and there is no way this game is
going to last long longer than I think
maybe like maybe like one hour in total
because I had all the time in the world
I was blitzing out everything my
opponent still had quite a lot of time
since he knew a lot of this position
anyways except for the move d4 but that
would not have led to anything special
for white so here I played The Rook f8
and in this position
the expectation I had was my opponent
will never ever play Rook to E3 because
it's super passive and I mean even if
they do it's very difficult for them to
make progress so my expectation was on
the along the lines King G2 Rook G6 can
goes anywhere and basically I attack the
pawn and this will end in a repetition
but of course this is not what happened
I completely overlooked my opponent's
opportunity on the next move so it's
very important task in hand to go for
this position it's white to play
so of course if I say that the game
ended with King G2 Rook G6 King H1 in
repetition we definitely would not be
having this lecture because this would
just be a very short draw but it this
game is actually much more complicated
than a short draw
so
I played the rook f8 and here my
opponent played a move that I was really
not expecting
um
at that moment it took me a while to
understand it but my brain started
working like the uh like my opponent and
like other Grandmasters basically
throughout the tournament after this
game and then I eventually got my Norm
um so even if you go King E2 yeah it's
possible to go King E2 but I can go Rook
H6 put pressure on the H Pawn and if you
defend your H Pawn I can always even put
the Rook on H3 it'd be super annoying
about it and at the end of the day this
should still be a
um
quite easy draw for for me so
so another suggestion is rookie four and
this is uh this is a very very tricky
move actually because that's what my
opponent did so Rook E4
but what's the idea right in the game I
was thinking okay rookie 4 is kind of
smart but it gives up this Pawn but he
also just wants to go for my A7 Pawn
so what I did I basically took they took
and then I took again
and um
yeah so we have another important
position
um in hand
so of course we have to consider and
calculate through K4 and this is very
important because rookan games kind of
um
yeah important yeah you're right with
rookie four but we kind of of course
have to
have to understand what's the idea
behind behind rookie 4 right so what can
whites what should white do next or what
does the idea of both sides this is in
my opinion a very important important
moment that we should take some time and
just try to figure out what is happening
so it is
um white to play
here
King G2 now is one suggestion Rook A4 is
definitely a suggestion that I am
suggesting
what else
it's very very important to understand
what is happening here and this is
the thing is when I of course mention it
it's kind of easy to look for a Nuance
but in a real game you kind of don't
look for a nuance and the tough part is
Bishop F6 is actually wrong because of
what is about to happen so the moment I
told you Bishop F6 is not a good move is
because what is about to happen in the
game otherwise Bishop F6 is Perfectly
Natural a good move
um although you're trading the Bishops
and so on the Activity part of it is
satisfactory so you're not really
trading but rookie 4 takes takes takes
this moment is extremely
extremely important to understand and
this is actually how GMS usually spend
their time during a game and calculate
I still had quite a lot of time here as
far as I remember because I was still
playing fast
and I always like to play Fast anyways
so
I I really enjoy the
doing that quite a lot and I still do
um
King G2 is possible
but
I'm not sure I don't want to give
anything away just yet well if you go H4
then I am probably not
too concerned I would say maybe I'm
wrong but I don't think I'm too
concerned because your opponent H4 will
be super weak and even if you go Rook
there and there I will always be able to
collect your Pawn as well so that
doesn't really scare me
um
just yet
white has the open file but does not
seem like much
yeah the open file alone doesn't make
too much
in this sense because the the king is
defending every entry Square
so
that's not really the the issue
for
for black
can we play D4
I mean even if you play D4 I think you
are allowing ideas like Rook C3 now all
of a sudden that were not there before
so D4 would actually help
um
help black quite a bit Yeah so let's
let's analyze what would happen if I go
Rook A4 right so why is this not the
correct move or maybe it's the correct
move it's attacking the pawn on A7 and
you just want to push that pawn down the
board and this is the most natural move
my opponent just played Rook E4 so if
the move Rook A4 is not going to be
analyzed then it's pointless and that
has to be the first thing you analyze
but after Rook A4
here I would play this move Rook H3 and
it's very important because if you take
my Pawn I take your Pawn
and I get quite some counter play here I
get my Rook behind the pawn and I should
be able to create enough counter play
and I have a pass Pawn myself so this
should not be any trouble for me
um in this position however after Rook
H3 my opponent is very likely that they
will play this move King to G2 they will
attack my rook and here in this
situation I can actually play a couple
of moves but I would probably play
something like Rook H5 or Rook H6 with
the idea that if you take my Rook I give
you a check
and now you can go to four different
locations and whichever file you choose
to go to I will be going to the other
file so if you play King H3 or something
I will be going Rook F6 if you go back I
will give you a check
if you go here I will go I can check you
too but I can also just go there if you
go to G3 I will still check you so you
cannot get out of this Loop basically
and that will be a draw without giving
up either of your pawns so that's why my
opponents decided not to do Rook to A4
because this is quite an annoying thing
to deal with
so here as it was correctly pointed out
in the chat my opponent played this move
Rook H4
with the idea to attack this Pawn on H7
so his first inducing me to play this
move H6 which I don't have a choice
and here is very important moment
because
black sorry white as a choice they can
obviously play the same Rook A4
with the idea to attack the pawn but
there is this kind of like Rook H3 kind
of ideas like we just saw and I can do
the same thing from here basically
without with the opponent H6 but also
they have this move Rook G4 and what is
the difference between the two right
well if you go Rook G4 first which
probably was the right move and he
didn't play it
um I I would have to respond with either
the move G5
or my Rook dropping back to F7 so that I
can keep
this Motif alive
on the fifth rank so let's see the
difference if I play G5 here now I no
longer have this concept of
Rook dropping down in this situation so
I cannot do any of the things I have
just mentioned long some time ago I have
to drop back here basically and I cannot
do this check business anymore because I
have my Pawn on the way
and therefore that doesn't make too much
sense
um
practically speaking I should maybe try
to play something like this and if he
captures play something like C4 try to
create some sort of an activity and hope
for some Rook end game and try to defend
but it would just be as tough as
defending any other Rook end game versus
an experienced Grandmaster and if you
take maybe I kind of Swing my rook and
try to swing around and do something to
win some pawns this was some computer
line maybe not the best line at this
moment but that would be the Hope
however I could also play this move Rook
to F7
so that if my opponent plays Rook A4
then I can play Rook F5 and then if Rook
takes A7 Rook H5 and we have seen this
sort of an idea before right if King G2
Rook goes there King goes up rook goes
there and we have seen this type of a
method before if you go here anywhere it
doesn't matter I stick
check if you go towards me I go there
and this would be a draw so Rook F7
would be definitely uh the move to play
in this type of position
but I would actually be forced to play
Rook F7 rather than a choice I don't
really have a choice I have to find the
move Rook back to F7 and then play on
from there but here my opponent played
Rook A4
which is probably not as accurate as
Rook G4 but what's the difference like
how can you even tell why Rook G4 Rook
A4 is not the most accurate in a game
versus Rook
um sorry why is Rook G4 K4 is better
versus Rook A4 immediately and what is
the difference because
it's not so obvious at least to me and
it was not obvious at all until a
certain time so so what is the the
difference here
zoa says I would have gone King C6 you
can definitely go King C6 at some point
but that means you're going to be giving
up this pawn and you will be playing
this position
um for a while however
it's better to maybe look for some
counter play immediately like that or
maybe like this so yeah I guess question
to the viewers is what's the difference
why is Rook G4 okay for such a big deal
I mean it kind of gives it away at this
point
um but it's it's very very important to
understand the nuances and the
differences between the two so it's it's
kind of a challenge I would say during
the game because no one tells you oh you
have to first include Rook G4 and then
play the move Rook A4 rather than Rook
A4 immediately because there's x y z no
one tells you that so in an actual game
I think the best way to do that is
calculate every single alternative and
try to figure it out for yourself which
one you like better which one you don't
like
so as I mentioned Rook G4 would have
been better but here I played this move
Rook to
Rook to F5 which I think is a dubious
move although it's the idea
it's the idea we just talked about it it
would have been forced I would have been
forced to play Rook F5 had my opponent
chosen to play Rook G for Rook A4 so he
could have forced me to play Rook F5
which is pretty much the only logical
move in the situation to do this but in
this scenario I am not forced to play
Rook F5 I actually have
the option of playing Rook to H3
attacking the pawn but I was worried
about one thing and actually this is the
thing that he thought is uh is good for
him that's why he played it because he
was going to go King G2 and I was going
to go Rook H5 and Only In This Moment
instead of taking here because then we
have the drawing mechanism his idea was
to play this move Rook to G4 and I was
practically speaking very afraid of this
because
um
I really didn't want to play the move G5
here because after I played the move G5
I think I was a little scared that this
Rook will never ever be able to make it
to the game as far as I remember
computers still think that this position
is holdable but it still looked a little
bit scary to me and I'm looking at the
leeches engine it's giving around 1.5 if
I remember correctly it's around that
line around the lines of 1.5 maybe a
little less after G5 but then if I don't
go G5 I sort of have to play this move
Rook G5 and to my eyes this was
very difficult to evaluate when I
compared it with the move Rook F5
instead of Rook H3 so I saw this
position and I wasn't sure about the
pawn end game and therefore I decided to
not play this
um
this position so
yeah
so this is not what I did
um
and therefore I played this move
Rook to F5
so again it's uh
again it's a critical moment I would say
not here but after Rook H5 so he took my
Pawn I played Rook to H5
um the difference with the pawn and H6
you could play G6 I mean yes that's true
but also
um yeah sort of provoking H6 also was
important and then yeah so that's a good
observation I have problems in cleanly
converting winning positions what would
you suggest
um I think you just have to play out a
lot of winning positions and you just
have to improve your tactics that's
that's all
um and then position Ultra so you have
to basically improve in all areas to be
able to improve winning clean winning
positions
so anyways I played Rook H5 and this is
once again um white to play What Would
you play with white here
so we will have to accelerate at some
point because this game is quite long
actually
um The Rook end game is the fun part but
also you're going to be surprised on how
how this game is going to be continuing
and that's kind of the reason I always
say this is the game that made me a GM
because
we essentially had the opening
preparation phase and then we had an end
game with two Rooks versus two Rooks now
we're having a clean Rook end game and I
guess we're gonna see what's gonna be
coming up soon so here anyways I don't
want to spend too much time my opponent
played this move extremely strong Rook
A4
Rook A4 with the idea I guess we're
going to be understanding that very soon
I took on H2 obviously that was my idea
and in here
um
black sorry white has a choice right
white again once again has a choice
it can be the move King G1 and it can
also be the move Rook G4
so those are the main choices that white
has and I'm of course kind of helping
out in this situation because if I don't
say white as a choice and if I don't
mention the choices there might be other
potential candidate moves but to just
make things easier we're just going to
be talking about these two moves so here
one move is correct and one move is
wrong but it's really once again very
very tough to evaluate
um
when it comes to evaluating this
position I think one has to be sort of
really curious about this position
because both of the moves they kind of
look the same I would say because at the
end of the day white usually is thinking
they're almost winning here because they
have a very nice outside past Pawn that
is a big distraction and this past Pawn
is not really doing too much so let's
let's kind of think about it so Rook G4
is a candidate move and then there's
King G1 so let's kind of start with a
little bit both so and the chat is
saying Rook G4 so Rook G4 actually was
the move played in the game so let's
kind of talk about the other one and
then talk about drug G4 and now there is
a suggestion of King G1 because it
prevents the check so why is this check
important or is it important we will
have to discuss that but if King G1 was
played
I don't have a choice other than playing
The Rook to H5 because if I go Rook H3
you can always push my Rook to H5
anyways so I might as well just go Rook
H5 in the first place and after Rook
goes to H5
let's say white swings The Rook to G4
they're attacking the pawn the last
thing I probably want to do is this move
G5 it looks super scary as far as I
remember the computer still holds this
yeah the position is around 0.6 so the
computer can hold this but while my
opponent has an outside passed Pawn I
really do not want to lock my rook in
it's practically speaking very difficult
for me to defend this position so I
would have probably played something
along the lines King C6 takes and then
maybe something like C4 just to get some
sort of activity on the fifth Rank and
try to claim that I can hold this end
game somehow but it would be a very
tough choice or maybe I would have opted
for a G5 who knows but it would have
been certainly a tough choice
um
so this would basically be pretty much
uh forced play and who knows if I could
defend this or not so
but my opponent played The Rook Rook G4
move which actually comes with the
difference his idea however was he
wanted me to play G5 by force because
after G5 is played then my opponent can
play something like this and I would not
have a choice to
think about playing something like C4
and Rook A5 but the trade-off to Rook G4
is that it allows this check and here
probably my opponent was thinking the
opponent game is a win which probably it
looks winning I I mean I'm not gonna say
if it's a win or a draw because although
the game is one and a half it doesn't
mean if the opponent game was a win or
draw anything could have happened
um
and he played this move Rook G1 takes
takes so we reached after all we reached
opponent
um there are many possible moves in this
position but we sort of have to
understand what the winning idea for my
opponent is and then maybe try to figure
out how I can
um defend against it so I will not go in
extreme detail of every single line of
opponent game because upon any game like
this will take a long time to analyze
and there is quite a lot of nuances but
generally speaking the idea is
conceptually very easy
and when you look at this position
you're like oh this pawn and game must
be winning because there is a huge
outside past Pawn that I have to deal
with with my king although I also have
outside pass pawns you have this F Pawn
that can be used as a basically
splitting up my pawns into two uh to
collect all these pawns so White's idea
is quite straightforward he wants to
basically get some sort of uh structure
like this
d3c4b3 A4 where all the pawns are
Untouchable and then just somehow bring
his King in the middle of my two Pawns
even if he cannot bring it in the middle
he can at least approach them and then
use the F Pawn to sort of break the two
pawns whether it's the pawn is on G6 on
G5 it doesn't matter so he will be
targeting this Pawn with that pawn and
as soon as he does that he will be
collecting two of the pawns and winning
upon four versus three in the queen side
and that's kind of
very straightforward when you think
about it I mean
if black does nothing white is just
gonna do that why he's just gonna walk
his King push this Pawn up the board
when I take he's gonna take either thing
and then go back to the other one since
I don't have any activity so it looks
completely winning hence my opponent
played Rook G4
and I cannot disagree with that because
it looks completely lost for me but here
I figured out his idea was to go C4
so I was like I'm not going to let you I
play this move D5
how did either player know how to
evaluate this well we were kind of
evaluating by calculating and kind of
figuring out ideas here and there
um
but C4 and other Pawn C4 you can control
the two pawns On A and B and create
another pass one so okay first of all I
started with D5 I didn't quite
understand what you are saying so I
guess we'll talk about it but it's very
difficult for me to create a past tone
by the way because
I cannot create one when I have doubled
pawns my opponent is not forced to take
anything I give them and even if I take
them
it's just very difficult to like
Force um
a past Pawn like he has four of them I
have three of them but like it basically
looks like two I played D5 and my
opponent played C3 here well what's the
idea of C3 I would say idea of C3 is
quite simple he wants to go D3 and then
C4 why not D3 immediately
I think it was still possible but in
this position if I remember correctly I
can just simply play like C4 and try to
already separate the pawns uh into two
right into multiple pieces that I can
kind of deal with so I would take you
would take and even if you tried to do
something I would basically get the
situation that he has here and I would
or just to show it right let's say he
does something like A4
um A4 I take they take I just bring my
king and then let's say they also do the
same thing
right let's say they run I run they run
right and then here I would go C5
same idea I see what they apply
uh he would go F4 and I would go
something like this split up my Pawns
I would split up your Pawns
and we would have a very nice
Grandmaster draw at the end
this would be brilliant
but here my opponent did not want to go
for any of that he played the move
C3 the point being if I go C4 and I want
to trade some things he's gonna go b4a4
there is no way I can force any trades
now even if I get this Pawn to C5 let's
say I go here there and then there he's
just gonna start bringing his King
if I go C5
he couldn't care less he would just go
there and now I my king is useless I
can't go and grab
even if I go D4 he's never gonna take it
he's just gonna start pushing and just
to demonstrate the winning idea I cannot
take this once again he's gonna go F5
bring the king
or any move it doesn't matter I'm not
even looking at the queen side
and then he's going to split
and then grab all of them
and then come back and then grab all of
these not a problem it's easy
and this would be game over so I can't
go C4
so what do I do I go King C6 okay it's
not so clear what I'm trying to do but
here my opponent goes A4 well he
somewhat has to go A4 because my idea in
this scenario is if I can get my king to
B5
successfully then I will go C4 and this
time if you go before my king can
actually invade because the C Pawn will
be defending the B Pawn so if you kind
of do whatever you want
I will just do this
and try to create some counter play
let's say and if you play B4 I got C5 oh
I don't have C5 I'll just go here and
just just win the ball and if you try to
go for some Central pawns I will start
running my Pawn too because I also have
my own uh passer
but anyways I played King C6 my opponent
will not even allow me to get any
counter play and here they play D3
because my idea was I wanted to go there
and then go C4 to split up the pawn on
A4 with the B3 Pawn but as soon as I
attempted that I was not allowed to even
touch
ah touch that point
so again it's a tough moment I would say
because I don't know how to even defend
this position and I guess I will give it
as a task to to the audience what would
you play here how would you even try to
make a draw
or is this a draw or is it lost so I
don't know I cannot reveal everything
but it's tough position I can only tell
you that
um
it is black to play
foreign
yeah it's kind of tricky yeah you can go
C6 here but he's not gonna do anything
right he's just gonna bring his King so
if you go C6 or something he's just
gonna bring his King at least that's his
idea and then pushed upon and then we
have talked about this before anyways I
played D4 at least you know kind of
keeping the pawn alive
he played F4 very logical I played G6 at
least I want to keep his Pawn there I
played King before he played King G3 so
I don't think I have to repeat the idea
once again but
um my opponent wants to go King G4 F5 so
if I don't do anything if I just wait
with my king king A5 King before he's
gonna go King G4 he's gonna go F5 and
then after I take he's gonna take go
there take and then bring his King
slowly somewhere here
and then just take everything here and
then just promote all of the Pawns
so it's very important moment now Moment
of Truth what do we do how do we even
defend how can we try to make a
difference draw in this position
it's move number 36 but I still have
quite a lot of time because I played the
opening with full full speed so
I had a lot of extra time
and got into this position is the queen
end game after
King C3 King D3 King E2 losing well how
do you even get a queen end game that's
a problem because I don't think I
promote at the same time I think I am
definitely short on tempo so that is
something to to evaluate but everyone is
suggesting King C3
you're saying we both promote okay let's
see if you do A5 you take
I push show me how you promote
here
you want to go King E2 sorry
King E2
okay push
you sure about King E2 you're not gonna
you're not gonna be too happy about what
you're going to see soon you're not even
threatening anything
you're not you're not even threatening
anything that's the sad part even if you
promote I get I made you here
so that's that's very funny but that's
kind of sad also you're not even
threatening to to promote
um
and you're not at the same you're not
promoting at the same time definitely
not so it's very very important very
important nuance
um
but yeah King C3
A5 takes there
um and okay at least
um
yeah so there is still more to calculate
unfortunately
and this is the reason
I told in the beginning of the stream
this is the game that really makes me
unders make me understand how I can
calculate like a GM and actually how to
play like a gym because as in I am I I
was not sure what's the difference
between an IM and GM like I couldn't
tell I was like why why what am I even
missing why am I not a grand master yet
but after this game I was like okay
these are the things I don't know
because in a normal game no one tells
you actually I calculated this line King
C3 takes King C2 D3 D2 and I was like
okay this is it it's a draw he's gonna
give a check I'm gonna go here
and I'm gonna promote next move so with
full confidence I played the move
King C3 and I was like okay this is a
drone
but then what happens is we play all
that and then all of a sudden I realize
my opponent can give a check on e4 so it
was a pawn and game that suddenly turned
into a
Queen end game out of nowhere and I
wasn't expecting this because I was
really expecting a handshake after
basically second hour and before even
the time control like yeah okay we made
the chime control it's already move 40
but somewhere around here I was
expecting check check check draw okay
let's go home very nice
but I missed Queen E4 completely so that
brings me to the point and this is
actually a a prophylaxis lesson at the
same time in this position the correct
move was the move C6 that did not even
cross my mind but the idea is to prevent
Queen A8 to E4 and then it would be a a
draw let's say if my opponent played
something like King G4 I would go here
then we would do
this this this this this all that same
same thing nothing different same thing
and that's why now he has to take the
Perpetual otherwise I promote and I'm
actually gonna probably win if you let
me promote with a check so that's why I
had to play C6 and if I played C6 the
game would have been over in actually in
no time
that would actually be over in no time
so let's say he played something like
King F2 just to understand
um
how this game would have ended in a draw
so let's say he goes here I would have
played something like H5 and then he can
go F5 takes takes
um
let's say King here there
would have been a blunder but he has to
push of course takes push there push
push push
push and this would just end in a draw
right
and he has to give a perpetual
there are many other lines but for
example if I even continue the weight
like if he did King F2 King A5 King F3
King B4 King a so all of this let's say
happens
even if I'm like casually waiting even
if we go for this this would just also
be a draw and this is the one I like the
most because uh this would just end with
a bear King you know and this would
actually be a nice way to end end the
game so here I just played King C3
rushing it without even thinking I was
like okay it's easy to draw so let's
just go for it and then guess what
happens we just entered as you guys said
round two we're playing a queen end game
all of a sudden come on
it's prevents Queen E4
when the when when the pawn is here you
cannot jump there that's the point
and then takes here my opponent played
Queen there centralizing the queen and
then I played Queen C3 and my opponent
played F5 and here I was a little
frustrated because this is not what I
expected and I'm playing a 2600 Grand
Master it's it's kind of uh very
difficult to like handle it because
I was hoping this would have been a draw
a long time ago he plays F5 and here I'm
like already looking for some cheap
tricks I give a check really hoping for
King H5 Queen G5 of course it's not
going to happen and here once again I
miss a very difficult draw but it was
more out of frustration I wasn't even
looking for the draw I'll just show this
for the sake of time but here I play
this my opponent should I mean if I
played Queen D4 opponent has to go Queen
G4 because if they take the queen if
they push or just I'll just show you
guys if you take I just take and if you
push we promote at the same time and
this would also be a
via draw so after
um
after I go Queen D4 he has to go Queen
here and I wasn't looking for the draw
but the draw would have been something
very forcing I wasn't looking for it so
I couldn't find it although I saw this
move and I thought okay this is also
something but I gave up the pawn for
free and I couldn't like really
understand how H5 even helps my position
because even if I check him around he's
just gonna run away but the weird move
here is that I go back to D4 so I just
sacrificed the pawn but I bring my queen
back to D4 and even if you try to go
away I will check you if you go to G5
I'll check you
if you go up I check you and if you go
to H3
um I can basically just check you around
and then go back to D4 whenever needed
and this would would also be a draw and
if you go here I will just continue
checking you until you've fed up and
then you have to go to H4 and I go back
to D4 so I missed this draw as well so I
just started playing and I got
frustrated I played C6 and then the game
just went on and on and this F Pawn is
just painful it's just there and it's
it's just difficult to deal with
um I could never take it my opponent
didn't give it away and I'm just
defending but my time is starting to
tick down because now we made the time
control but I'm burning a lot more time
because it's a queen end game not
everything is easy to calculate there
are millions of checks millions of
captures and all that and um
it's just getting tougher and tougher I
took this Pawn on C4 and the like
complications in the middle of the game
but the F Pawn is going down the board
the computer is always giving zeros in
every single position
um
but it's not easy for me to understand I
just don't have enough time even if I
have time I cannot really evaluate and I
eventually
just continued giving checks hoping that
my opponent would at some point
I don't know blunder something or allow
me to make a draw or something and then
here anyways I'm not commenting too much
about this part of the game because
there is a lot of um
there's a lot of weird computer lines
that probably we don't really want to
talk too much about but the position has
been going winning for wise to drawing
and back and forth A lot of times so the
the tables have been turned multiple
times but I don't want to stick to the
details of things I just want to give
the concepts of of this thing so anyway
somehow his King made it to B7 and then
this Pawn is very close to promoting and
it eventually did promote so I did
blunder
significantly at some point and he
promoted
and here my opponent took this and here
I played C3 so this is the next critical
moment so what have we seen so far we
have seen extreme opening preparation
and then the next thing we saw was um
two Rooks and game two Rooks versus two
ropes then we saw Rook versus rook and
then we saw opponent game and after a
pawn and game we saw a queen end game
and after a queen end game now we're
witnessing a queen versus pawn and these
types of situations are tough because
with the c Pawn you have to be extremely
careful there are a lot of drawing
positions if my Pawn was here if my king
was there and if this Pawn was missing
it would have been a draw but the
question is what is the evaluation of
this position and how do you
um how do you win this type of position
with white or is it a draw or what is
the evil so
I guess I will ask the the chat what do
you guys think about this position what
what is the email
what is happening because the C Pawn
tends to be a draw quite a lot of times
but is this one of the times but they
also say that when there is an extra
Upon This should always be winning
because there is no stalemate right so
so It's Tricky should be winning for
whites yeah it's it's is it winning how
do you win what's your move
you have to prove if it's a win even
conceptually
um yeah
you see it
with you win okay how do you win for me
okay
I can buy myself a move
multiple times okay
yeah but okay let's say queen B8 right
let me go here
sure
okay
let's say
let's say I go here
okay
one Queen A1
very good so you are trying to get the
queen here
so let's say let's say I would not leave
let's say I stay in front of my Pawn
so I don't let you Queen A1 right
Queen before let's say I go here
King comes
okay let's say I play
Ed
Queen B1 is it over
here
the moment you bring the king I push
can be two okay no problem
here yeah
okay I'll just move anywhere it doesn't
matter
yeah this is this is important so
let's see are you here
so Queen so
how do you make sure you don't stalemate
though I think you already did yeah
with the King here it's already
so you can get an extra move
so how
let's see sorry well you can't go there
I take that right
you mean here King E5 you know you can
go there I'll go C5
trying to stack the spawn
and believe it or not this is actually a
drone
which is very surprising you're
initially right the position is winning
yeah but I'll just show the nuances so
this position is winning for sure 100 I
think the easiest way the best way which
I always think about it is you and
you're right you want to get the queen
there
preferably you want to get the queen
here I mean that's kind of easier and
then it would just be winning so I think
the easiest way to win is just give a
check force my king here and then play
Queen D4 which he saw in the game by the
way we talked about this after the game
but he said he was concerned about the
C5 push because of course if you take
but also notice this is at the seventh
hour of the game this is not like we
just started playing the game and he's
Super Fresh it's literally seven hours
in it's past 10 10 p.m and he totally
forget forgot that he can play this move
Queen E5 or anywhere on this diagonal it
doesn't matter and this is completely
winning because now for me to be able to
push this Pawn I need to move my king
and even if I move the king anywhere now
you bring your king and after C2 you
just play Queen to A1 and that's it
it's always going to be lights out and
he thought that this is just easy to win
he just played Queen C5 and he was
basically expecting a resignation but
already this move itself is a draw and
it's done there is no way after this
move Queen C5 and it's so shocking
because like after C2 he he just
couldn't believe his eyes he still
played on forever but there is no way
after this weird
position it's just a draw and um
yeah okay he tried he brought his King I
brought my king he gave some checks he
did everything what we all would do
right if I go King A1 you take the pawn
there is no Stillman King C1 King D6
King D2 of course I can't really do much
and then he just gives me some checks
and his idea is just like we saw in the
position if you play King C5 this is a
draw because I will go King there and
now you cannot take my opponent it's a
stalemate because you just put your king
in front of my Pawn that's the only Pawn
that I would try to move and this would
be a stalemate
so that's why what my opponent did was
okay he was like I'll check you around
and then I'll bring my king on E5 just
like it was suggested King E5 and I will
try to go from there but now I go C5
and as you all probably might know when
you're giving these checks you have to
give a check from B4 at some point of
before this square but now you cannot do
that my Pawn controls this Square so
out of frustration okay he just plays on
gives a check I go King C3 and now you
don't even have a choice you basically
have to take this point you can still
check around but it's not going to
change anything if you check here I go
King B2 you don't even have Queen before
check so it's kind of upsetting so he
ended up taking this Pawn but now this
is an easy draw
but here my opponent play Queen E2 I
still have to be careful though in this
position so what do you do with black
it's still King A1 yes King A1 is very
important so that if they take it still
made but why not King B1
King C4 wins exactly
and this so I still had to be careful
and this is move 96 I'm like extremely
tired but my opponent is still like
finding resource after resource to try
to trick me into blundering something
potentially so I played King A1 and then
he played Queen D2 and then the game
ended in a draw but what's the what's
the drawing idea if he goes King C4
here
it's quite simple but I think it's quite
nice
it is drunk between V1 King here and
then here I would have just played this
just just for the beauty of things
but that's why I always ask it because
Queen C1 is easy draw but this is just a
cuter draw but in the game after all
that we just played on and at the end
he just took this pawn and um
yeah that that was a that was a win so
um
the question in the chat is can you show
the one difference why the position was
winning well the the reason why it was
winning is I can't push my Pawn to C2
so
if you I mean you can do any other
technique by the way I just like this
queen D1 Queen D4 because I cannot get
my Pawn to C2 that's just my mindset
um
Queen C5 was the mistake because it
allowed uh C2 and then after that it
just lights out because the thing is the
problem is this King if the king is like
somewhere on like somewhere in front of
this Pawn like on e4 or on even on H4
probably is still winning but with the
King trying to come from behind it would
have to block the pawn or has to go
around like from here to there just like
in the game it did this and then did
that because it couldn't block this Pawn
so you had to go around it which spent
too much time and the pawn on C5
actually guards critical moments so
allowing C2 was critical but yeah this
game overall was um
103 moves it lasted more than seven
hours probably like seven hours like 15
minutes I was very exhausted and I
actually lost the next round but then at
the end of the tournament I actually got
a GM Norm so I was very happy about it
and then the next tournament I became a
GM but I really think that it was
because of this game because my opponent
kept on finding resource after resource
and I wasn't calculating any of this in
a game like I was just playing moves
just to make moves and I was always
wondering what is the difference between
a GM and an IM or even anyone else and
this game was a huge lesson for me like
there's always a resource you have to
defend you have to be active you have to
calculate precisely and the nuances like
even the Nuance in this position where
I'll just go all the way back this was
like multiple end games end game after
end game when he played this move rookie
4 I actually started figuring out okay
this is actually tougher than I thought
and here I was expecting Rook A4 and it
will be an easy draw and then my
opponent goes through cage four and then
I somehow end up in a pawn and game like
here I was expecting okay we're gonna
shake hands he's gonna go King G2 I'm
gonna give him a check he's going to go
to H file I'll repeat we're gonna make a
draw no none of that happened he played
Rook A4 he sacked this one we somehow
ended up in a pawn menu that pawn and
game turned into a Queen end game
because of my blunder because I wasn't
thinking if I was thinking I would have
found this move C6 here I would not have
had to play the Queen end game that I
played in the game because I was just
lazy in calculating
and stuff like that but yeah that was
the end of that game and this was one of
the key moments so I'll just leave it at
that and yeah thank you all for watching
and
I'll see you all in another lecture
[Music]
foreign